ومشاهدينا ننقل لكم هذه الصور التي تصلنا
الان مباشره من مدينه بافلو في ولايه
نيويورك الامريكيه كما نشاهد من خلال هذه
الصور العاصفه الثلجيه تتواصل ونلاحظ ايضا
ان المدينه تعاني من شلل تام طبعا
المعلومات التي وردتنا تتحدث عن اناس
علقوا بالثلج في سياراتهم طبعا هناك عدد
من القتلى ايضا عدد من الاصابات انقطاع في
التيار الكهربائي وايضا في الماء
اذا شلل كامل يصيب هذه المدينه مدينه
بافلو في نيويورك بسبب تراكم الثلوج وطبعا
وصفت هذه العاصفه بانها الاقصى التي تمر
على البلاد ادت الى اغلاق المطارات تاجيل
الرحلات والغائها وايضا الى قطع الطرقات
الرئيسيه من منطقه الى اخرى وكمان نشاهد
هذا الشلل التام في هذه المدينه الان لا
سيارات لا حركه للناس لا كهرباء لا تدفئه